in july and august temperatures dipped
below freezing in parts of brazil
causing the worst frost in decades
fields that used to look like this
quickly turned to this
now months later you may notice the
price of your coffee going up so how did
one bad weather event in one region
rattle the entire global coffee market
let's find out
brazil grows more coffee than any other
country and it produces about a third of
what we drink here in the u.s
and that area that was hit by the frost
it's considered the most important
coffee growing region in the country
gustavo guimaras is a brazilian
agronomist who's worked in the coffee
industry for more than two decades
this was the worst
frost in my
professional life i saw so far over
whatsapp he showed us these fields full
of dead and browned trees he says the
younger trees were completely destroyed
and will have to be taken out of the
ground and some of the older trees had
to be cut all the way down to the stumps
yeah so we had to come with them like a
chainsaw and cut it out
so a new tree will come out
and this would take like
two more years to start producing
and then he showed us the many other
trees that were damaged but not
destroyed they'll produce coffee next
year but not nearly as much as they were
expected to
these were the branches that we were
expecting to have coffee
in 2022 to make matters worse the frost
followed a bad drought in brazil so the
trees were already suffering
gustavo says it's possible that brazil
will lose 10 percent of its harvest next
year
to put that in perspective that
basically equals 20
of what americans drink in a year
how many years do you think it will take
brazil to bounce back from this
tough question
i would say at least at least three
years
three years if the weather is good
exactly
so clearly there's a coffee crisis in
brazil but why is it a big deal for the
global coffee industry and all of us
coffee drinkers for that i called carlos
mara he's been researching the coffee
industry for 15 years and his name
frequently pops up in journal articles
he says the bean that's been affected in
brazil is the same kind of bean that's
most commonly consumed here in america
brazil
produces mainly arabica which is the
type of coffee that you're likely to
find in a sort of mid-range to upper
range
plan
in supermarkets but also in coffee shops
adding to the problem is the timing of
the frost arabica beans naturally cycle
between weak and strong years and this
was already supposed to be a weak year
so farmers were banking on next year's
harvest to boost their stockpiles
that's a big reason why the market
reacted sharply when the frost hit the
price of arabica beans soared to six
year highs as traders worried about a
lack of supply
those prices have remained high and now
you may start to notice them being
passed along to you depending on where
and how you drink your coffee giant
coffee companies like starbucks buy
their coffee more than a year in advance
and so far starbucks has said it's not
worried about its supply but small and
mid-sized coffee companies can't afford
to buy all their coffee that far in
advance and they're definitely feeling
the pinch
owners of coffee companies that i talked
to said brazilian beans are 75 percent
more expensive than they were just a few
months ago and they say that what
happens in brazil doesn't stay in brazil
if there's a shortage in brazil then
demand for coffee from other countries
rises and so do the prices
on top of rising costs coffee importers
and roasters are dealing with the same
supply chain headaches and rising
shipping costs that are affecting other
industries and those factors are pushing
prices higher too
so what does this mean for you and me
and the millions of people who became
work from home baristas over the last
year and a half
well price hikes will be most noticeable
for those of us who brew our own coffee
at home
carlos says the first thing to go will
be discounts and promotions at
supermarkets and then later in the year
you're likely to notice the price of the
actual bags of beans on the shelves
going up
back in brazil gustavo says the extent
of the damage won't be fully known until
the new year when the trees start to
flower
it's a lot of risk
it's a huge impression
and with scientists predicting that
extreme weather events could happen more
frequently he says farmers are
calculating whether coffee is even worth
growing at all
if you have strong feelings about coffee
and how much you're willing to pay for
it leave me a comment below
and if you like this video please
subscribe so you can join me as i cover
more news that's having an impact on our
lives